Nicholas friends are not giving up and
neither is her partner Paul
after two weeks of searching he told
Channel 5 that the police theory that
she fell into the river is wrong
personally and again this is just my
opinion
I'm
personally I'm 100 convinced it's not
the river
people don't just vanish Into Thin Air
it's absolutely impossible so something
has happened
something has happened
find out what it is
find out what it is my plea now is
personally
I want every house
every garage every art building
the land
scrutinized I Want It All searched I
Want It All scrutinized every piece of
it
every search has drawn a blank
police have been scouring The Wider
parts of the river wire where the water
level rises and Falls more quickly but
it is the same story
they found nothing in there to lead them
to Nicola
it is perhaps from here that you get a
better idea of the scale of the waters
these teams are now searching we are
four miles from the sea and within just
half an hour the waters have risen by a
couple of meters
Upstream friends are determined to keep
the flow of information going again
lining the busy Main Road of Saint
Michael's on wire near to the Riverside
bench where Nicola was last seen we
still have no evidence we still don't
have that vital bit of information that
can give a line of inquiry and that's
why today is so important to drive that
awareness once again that someone must
have seen something and the fact we've
got a key piece of road that we have no
information for that's almost what we're
Clinging On to today that that's going
to shed some light on the situation
as the days and now weeks pass it does
get harder to remain upbeat but Nicholas
friends and family are resolute
Lisa Dowd Sky News Lancashire